the Joe Rogan experience what's going on
with Iran caught a bunch of people that
they are claiming our CIA informants and
they may execute them yeah yeah they've
done this before they made this claim
before and look Iran is a that a couple
of parts of this that's one of the
heaviest lips in the business has been
Intel collection on Iran over the years
I'm not talking about just recently but
over the years it's been it's been very
difficult
they are extremely buttoned up over
there and they have an incredible level
of control over their population and
then which is you know at some point you
would think well maybe the population is
going to object to this but you know it
hasn't happened yet and so part of it is
they came out with this these 17
individuals that they claimed were
cooperating with the CIA in some fashion
or another and they you know they
claimed that they were fairly high level
individuals the IFA I don't believe
anything that comes out of their mouths
I don't believe them at all I think
they've they've they've got a long long
track record of lying about a variety of
things and so you know why would they
come out with this you know perhaps
they're cracking down and it doesn't
hurt to come out and if you're going
after some of these individuals anyway
why not put them put the paintbrush on
them that they're working for the CIA
and and that will appease some of the
population there um so I don't know I
I'm again I'm not buying it it has been
a difficult Intel task and and
collecting intelligence on on their
efforts with with their ballistic
missiles their nuke program as well has
always been has always been problematic
but again they've done this before where
they've talked about how we've wrapped
up a CIA spying Network and it's it's
kind of horseshit it's their propaganda
I think well yeah I mean I you know I
yeah that would be my take on it I don't
know what I mean I'm not I'm not
internal I'm not inside and and so you
know is it possible sure we've had we've
had networks wrapped up before by other
countries Cuba the Cuban Intel service
years ago right which was completely
built by the Russians by the way by the
old KGB they owned and operated the
Cuban Intel service for a long time
still do they
at one point wrapped up pretty much
everybody we had on island mhm and a lot
of people did we have over there three
no we had you know I don't remember the
numbers but it was it was a few yeah
let's just say it was it was it was not
good and they they had done a very good
it was from a from a counterintelligence
perspective it was a pretty impressive
effort so it's happened
Rush's you know done the same when we've
usually went with Russia usually when
we've got a traitor or a mole you know
somebody like Robert Hansen Jim
Nicholson Howard the Americans oh yeah
from what I understand it's a good show
it was a show based on the idea that at
one point in time there was a Russian
family that had come over here and
infiltrated and became American citizens
and seemed like you know Joe and Mary
next door right but really they were
Russian spies you don't had an aunt an
uncle named John Mary it's weird that
you would say that I literally had Nana
named Joe and Mary I've done some intel
on you buddy
yeah there was you know there was a
story the reason the Americans was was
created was written as do a lot of
things do based on some smart writer who
sees an opportunity because he reads a
newspaper all right years back to 2011 I
think it was we had a sleeper cell that
we wrapped up in Jersey there was there
yeah that's what just takes place right
and there was that one that the hot one
remember everybody Russian right and so
ring him over and then you look at you
think and they've had yeah I mean we
could I think she's forgetting what her
name was
you're a fat Deana watering your lawn
and she walked over stored yeah got high
heels on yeah wearing nothing but that's
not so much there's something about her
look I know there's some better knows
the integration ever knows yeah no she's
hot yeah you don't think that looks got
not there no that's not a good shot one
update check and she's never any makeup
now that's true that imagine
hurry up yeah put a little tartar up
east-european cheese liner on her she'd
be a chick catches you with a couple of
Jack Daniels and you got trouble oh my
gosh she walks across when you're mowing
the lawn and you're right so she and a
bunch of other people lived in in Jersey
in the suburbs and their whole reason
for being with just a spot people right
it was it wasn't they were not you know
these were not the heads of the
organization right so their job is spot
people live there be you know social
meet people that might be of interest
maybe it turns out that somebody in the
PTA where your kids go to school maybe
somebody's working for Raytheon er
they're working for some you know
interesting company that's what they do
so that's their job their job was
basically the spot and then you've got
other people in that chain of events who
are a little bit higher up the food
chain who then assess right and we'll
look at that person and go
yeah there's maybe there's something
that his person works for whatever
company and and you know that'd be it
could be it doesn't matter what the
company is by the way could be Qualcomm
could be you know think of one that
because the application could be Corning
could be anything and there's all sorts
of companies out there that that have
applications that may be of interest
from an Intel perspective for a hostile
state so then you know they do a little
assessment and maybe they come away and
go yeah
yeah that person's interesting job let's
develop a little relationship there now
maybe one of those individuals will work
on that relationship or maybe that
somebody else will come in you know
within this there's this group and
they'll develop a relationship and then
you know maybe they'll task the person
so maybe you say the guy works at a tech
company and you know you're gonna think
okay I want to see if this person has
any weaknesses you know how you know can
i leverage anything here and so what
you'll say is you know my kid you know
it's doing this school paper it's on you
know something and uh okay I can't you
know yeah they're just not getting in it
or they're not doing the research or
whatever hey do you have anything you
know and you're not asking for anything
classified you're just saying look you
work in a tech company you know don't
you have something that would be of
interest you know my kids got to write
the stupid paper and and you're not
looking for anything of Intel value
you're looking to see whether they'll
accommodate you will they actually come
back and go yeah well you know what we
got this and it's kind of interesting
and it's a you know research paper
that's you know been out in the press
for a long time but yeah it's
interesting hey you don't hands it over
well not maybe
got something right now you got
something that you can see that they
responded to a little task and then you
so you set the hook a little bit and
then you just keep on working on that so
in the meantime they're calling back to
the KGB and saying we have got who work
with Raytheon write notes information
just and they say it just like that that
very accident they keep jobs and
everything so they work to go to work
everybody go to work maybe they don't
maybe they're a spouse you know
stay-at-home spouse but what do they do
they hang out with other stay-at-home
spouses and create friendships because
of kids and the next thing you know you
all having dinners with each other and
you know if you like that Russian broad
she's banging everybody right no you
wouldn't do that that would be a very
disruptive thing to do in that community
it's not the premise of the Americans
I've seen the show but yeah I watched
one bank's people I watched I watched
about half an hour of the first episode
and the Knights get angry no no I just
sit there and I'm a very hard person to
watch shows like that with and so so my
wife was like I just can't no you can't
you can't sit here because it's like
yeah tell I'm going like but it was good
I understand it was good show with a
show where people play pool no I really
played pool Mike yeah